[Applaudissements]
hier mon luigi était revenue sur
l'émission de laurent ruquier puisque
laurent rue qui était notre invité hier
était revenue sur vous êtes en direct
exactement directement et aujourd'hui il
va revenir sur dany brillant fait ça il
me regarde il veut mais l'impression nom
d'anne il est tranquille je suis super
content en plus audard fait mes
recherches sur vous j'ai cherché des
photos de vous différentes époques c'est
que c'est hyper énervant parce que vous
ne vieillissez pas ça c'est vous en 1990
c'est ouf ça c'est beau la même chemise
de très bonne qualité c'est vous et vous
êtes tout le temps beau gosse alors même
en femme
vous êtes belle gosse d'ailleurs je vous
présente dany brillant tu as well as
quelque chose à un petit truc là nous
avons un look s'il met toujours beau
gosse ccra ni briand à williams est
toujours beau gosse à la retraite
regardez un peu la classe de papy
brillant ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
si confinement d'affilée mais toujours
beau gosse on dit bonjour à dany free on
[Applaudissements]
dirait mon sens ils attendent
on sait que sacha le base va se
rapprocher une bonne tête ça on a envie
de le monde il sera avec nous demain
sacha d'ailleurs c'est sacha dans deux
semaines l'achat des manuels et 6 ans
qui fait en belgique
badie cinéma d'ici alors j'ai fait un
peu le tour de toutes vos interviews et
je sais que ça va pas vous permet chez
eux obligés de commencer par votre
première télé c'était dans la chance aux
chansons avec pascal sera à mon avis à
mon avis ça sera pas la dernière
il s'appelle brillant fabien cas dany
brillant s'appelle brion remarqué très
brillant pour coincer merci pascal ait
chanté marchand
je ne pardonne
japon pas
je
les deux puis vous cartonnez malgré
votre terrible maladie l'a dernier
bouton o phobie la peur de fermer le
dernier bouton de votre chemise mais on
enchaîne to treat en parlant musicale
quel est l'artiste que tu as vu en live
et qui t'a vraiment impressionné aubin
j'imagine que comme tout le monde c'est
freddy mercury
allez c'est cadeau
[Musique]
je sais ça fait trois petits trucs de
revoir ce classique cet antiquaire
j'aimerais bien être comme ça à son âge
c'est là c'est un astre is our il a un
regard incroyable aidé à une pêche il
renaître place à phoenix et certains
modèles un modèle voilà c'est ça mais
plus qu'une voix vous êtes aussi un
physique à rendre fou de jalousie
patrick chan fresnes alors un petit
conseil bon patoche savez le sexe a
filmé malheureusement ça se travaille
pas et avec ce physique de playboy me
dis pas que vous auriez pas profité le
seul problème c'est que c'est un fidèle
du coup après les concerts ccc très
chaud c'est très caliente bondir à porto
rico
j'aime beaucoup porto rico aussi en tout
cas pour finir vous avez une vraie
histoire d'amour et ça c'est beau
s'appelle corey et s'est longtemps vous
êtes un sens assez bien de jour que
quand je dis je suis un fidèle
je parle de mon rôle dans une pièce de
terre de la sueur à minsk la bouche pas
ça mais sorti du contexte
non mais parce que attention attention
attention est là mais j'ai jamais j'ai
pas trop pb merci d'admettre qu'à bercy
décidé de reprendre des classiques de
charles aznavour certains chanteurs ont
actuels ont décidé de reprendre des
classiques de dany brillant et c'est le
cas de jul et russell [ __ ] avec
vient saint germain
saint germain
[Musique]
non
aussi maître gims avec quand je vois tes
yeux quand je vois tes yeux
quand j'entends
de joie quand je
je suis là
voir
[Musique]
double reprise de charisme sur ce sujet
[Applaudissements]
elles sont mieux qu'à la branche
montfort 1 parce que pour votre nouvel
album vous reprenez du charles naveau
faut savoir que c'est un sacré défi il
faut avoir du niveau pour reprendre sur
la nation parce qu'il y en a qui ont
essayé
il doit eu des problèmes je paye mythe
acteurs connus ou pas c'est chez moi je
sache et le serbe le web du bruit pour
johnny avait avoué une ovation pour
charles aznavour on
au pays des merveilles
il me semble
que l'âme
sereine
pénible au soleil les un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour charles aznavour
tofo nist dans la lan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour terminer en tout cas gros respect à
vous dany parce que vous n'avez jamais
arrêté de chanter et ça même quand vous
pouviez pas à payer vos factures edf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]